عندما سمعنا عن هجوم آخر
للحوثيين المدعومين من إيران قبالة سواحل
اليمن يبدو أنهم أه حاولوا
الهجوم أو أنهم هاجموا
سفينة تجارية وحاولوا الصعود إليها ومن ثم
مروحية تابعة للبحرية أه ترد النيران على
المعاول وأعتقد أنها تغرق ثلاثة  من بين
القوارب الأربعة، هذه هي المرة الأولى منذ
7 أكتوبر حيث أفهم أن الولايات المتحدة
قتلت أعضاء من
جماعة الحوثيين المتمردة المدعومة من إيران، ما رأيك في
هذا أم إلى أين يتجه هذا إلى عمار،
هذه خطوة كبيرة أه لأنه حتى الآن يا
رئيس  لقد حرص بايدن بشدة على
تجنب أن تقوم أه الولايات المتحدة بمهاجمة
هوديس بالتأكيد في اليمن
ولم يكن هناك كما لاحظت
اشتباك مباشر بين الأمريكان وأه
في هذه الحالة يبدو إذا كنت
تصدق الحساب الذي أه
القيادة المركزية لدينا  اتضح أنه ليس لدينا أي سبب
للشك في أن المثيرين في
الهجوم على سفينة حاويات م
فتحوا النار على مروحية تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية أو
مروحيات كانت قادمة لمساعدة أه
السفينة وفي تلك اللحظة قام
قادة المروحيات بالرد على
أنفسهم  - أغرق الدفاع ثلاثة من هذه
القوارب السريعة الأربعة الصغيرة التي كان أصحاب القلنسوة يستخدمونها
وقتلوا الطاقم في تلك القوارب الثلاثة، وقد
أصدر الجذابون منذ ذلك الحين
إعلانًا في الساعات القليلة الماضية فقط
قائلين إن 10 من مقاتليهم ماتوا أه
في هذا وتعهدوا بمواصلة الأمر.  لقد كان هناك
الكثير من الضغوط بما في ذلك
من البنتاغون أه على الرئيس بايدن
لأه التصرف بقوة أكبر آه ضد أصحاب
القلنسوة هنا ولإعادة تأسيس بعض
الردع وأعتقد أن الناس
ربما سيجلسون الآن
للحظة ويرون ما إذا كانت الأمور قد حصلت  من الصعب جدًا تحديد
الرسالة من هذا أو ما إذا كانوا
سيواصلون الهجمات،
وقد تكون بالضبط تلك
الدوامة التصعيدية التي
كان الرئيس يحاول
تجنبها.